in his book The Twilight of the idols
Friedrich nche history's most overrated
philosopher said he who has a why in
life can withstand almost any
how how am I going to get through this
horrible tragedy well if you know the
why if you understand the purpose you'll
find a way to endure in the Book of
Genesis Joseph's brothers sold him into
slavery in order to get rid of him the
next time they saw Joseph he was very
rich and very powerful and they were
terrified that he was going to kill them
but Joseph could eventually say in an
effort to comfort his brothers what you
meant for evil God meant for good Joseph
saw that even though there was a
malicious human cause of his suffering
there was a Divine Purpose using that
malicious human intent to achieve
something that would save countless
lives many centuries later a Jewish
Carpenter was executed by Roman soldiers
with the support of the Jewish religious
leaders they wanted to get rid of him
and they did for 3 Days the message of
Christianity in a nutshell is that what
they meant for evil God meant for good
think about what happened on the cross
Jesus of Nazareth was mocked beaten
tortured and killed the fogging would
have left the skin on his back back
hanging like ribbons his veins and
arteries would have been exposed his
wrists and feet were pierced with large
Nails because of the way he was
positioned on the cross he had to push
himself up on his pierced feet in order
to Exhale our word excruciating is
derived from Latin words meaning out of
the
Cross but we should also think about the
why the purpose why did Jesus die on the
cross as it turns out the the answer
goes far beyond the malicious human
cause the Bible offers dozens of reasons
Jesus came to die let's go through 10 of
them why did Jesus Come To Die reason
one to fulfill Old Testament
prophecy 700 years before Jesus walked
the shores of the Sea of Galilee the
prophet Isaiah wrote about someone who
would die for our sins and rise from the
dead
in Isaiah 53: 4-6 the prophet says this
surely he took up our pain and bore our
suffering yet we considered him punished
by God stricken by him and Afflicted but
he was pierced for our transgressions he
was crushed for our iniquities the
punishment that brought us peace was on
him and by his wounds we are healed we
all like sheep have gone astray each of
us has has turned to our own way and the
lord has laid on him the iniquity of us
all the crucifixion of the Messiah
wasn't something that caught God off
guard it was part of an eternal
plan reason two to establish a
covenant there are several covenants in
the Bible agreements between God and Men
God established a covenant with the
children of Israel which we read about
in the Old Testament but even in the Old
Testament there were prophecies about a
future Covenant a New Covenant in
Jeremiah 31 for instance we read the
days are coming declares the Lord when I
will make a New Covenant with the people
of Israel and with the people of Judah
it will not be like the Covenant I made
with their ancestors when I took them by
the hand to lead them out of Egypt
because they broke my Covenant though I
was a husband to them declares the Lord
Lord this is the Covenant I will make
with the people of Israel after that
time declares the Lord I will put my law
in their minds and write it on their
hearts I will be their God and they will
be my people no longer will they teach
their neighbor or say to one another
know the Lord because they will all know
me from the least of them to the
greatest declares the Lord for I will
forgive their wickedness and will
remember their sins no more God said
said that a new covenant was coming a
covenant that would bring forgiveness of
sins more than six centuries later Jesus
sat down for the last supper with his
disciples Matthew
26 while they were eating Jesus Took
bread and when he had given thanks he
broke it and gave it to his disciples
saying Take and Eat This is my body then
he took a cup and when he had given
thanks he gave it to them saying drink
from it all of you this is my blood of
the Covenant which is poured out for
many for the Forgiveness of
sins the New Covenant was established
through the blood of
Christ reason three to become a ransom
for
many remember that New Covenant we were
just talking about and how it's
connected to forgiveness of
sins the letter to the Hebrews compares
the old Covenant
and the New Covenant the author quotes
the passage we read from Jeremiah and he
argues that while the old Covenant was
outward and temporary the New Covenant
is Inward and eternal in chapter nine he
writes the blood of goats and Bulls and
the ashes of the hepher sprinkled on
those who are ceremonially unclean
sanctify them so that they are outwardly
clean how much more then will the blood
of Christ who through the eternal spirit
offered himself unblemished to God
cleanse our consciences from acts that
lead to death so that we may serve the
Living God for this reason Christ is the
mediator of a New Covenant that those
who are called may receive the promised
Eternal inheritance now that he has died
as a ransom to set them free from the
sins committed under the first Covenant
a ransom is a payment to set someone
free Christ died as a ransom to set them
free from the sins committed under the
first Covenant and this Echoes what
Jesus said in Mark
10:45 for even the son of man did not
come to be served but to serve and to
give his life as a ransom for
many reason four to demonstrate God's
love the god of the Bible is is perfect
in his attributes since God's justice is
perfect all sin must be punished if God
let some sin slide he wouldn't be
perfect in his justice but God's love is
also perfect which means that he's
vastly more loving than we are so much
so that he's willing to take the
punishment that we deserve upon himself
God loves Sinners so much that the
second person of the Trinity entered
into creation as Jesus of Nazareth in
order to pay the price for our sins in
Romans 5 the Apostle Paul writes you see
at just the right time when we were
still powerless Christ died for the
ungodly very rarely will anyone die for
a righteous person though for a good
person someone might possibly dare to
die but God demonstrates his own love
for us in this while we were still
sinners Christ died for us as the most
famous verse of any book in the history
of the world John 3:16 put it for God so
loved the world that he gave his one and
only son that whoever believes in him
shall not perish but have eternal
life reason five to give us his
righteousness some people can be
described as righteous even in the Bible
but that's a comparative righteousness
so and so is righteous compared to other
people when we compare ourselves to God
however all we can say is what the
prophet Isaiah said in Isaiah
646 all of us have become like one who
is unclean and all our righteous acts
are like filthy rags we all shrivel up
like a leaf and like the wind our sins
sweep us
away let me tell you something you you
should already know you might be good
compared to me I might be good compared
to someone else but we aren't good
enough to spend eternity with a perfect
being and there's nothing we can do to
make ourselves good enough to spend
eternity with a perfect being so if
we're going to spend eternity with a
perfect being we need a righteousness
that comes from someone other than
ourselves
how are we going to get this
righteousness Romans 3 but now apart
from the law the righteousness of God
has been made known to which the law and
the prophets testify this righteousness
is given through faith in Jesus Christ
to all who believe there is no
difference between Jew and Gentile for
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory of God and all are Justified
freely by his grace through the red
Redemption that came by Christ
Jesus and 2 Corinthians 5:21 God made
him who had no sin to be sin for us so
that in him we might become the
righteousness of
God the Greek word for gospel means good
news the good news is that God gives the
righteousness of Christ to people who
did absolutely nothing to earn it
reason six to transform us into God's
temples since we have the righteousness
of Christ we can be what we were created
to be in John 6:38 Jesus tells his
followers that he came down from
heaven but where was he going when he
left heaven and came to Earth as Jesus
of Nazareth was he going to
Bethlehem was he going to
Nazareth was he going to the
Cross was he going to the tomb Jesus
went to all of these places but he had a
particular destination in mind he tells
us exactly where he was going in the
last two verses of John 17 where the
Divine son shortly before his
crucifixion says to the father righteous
father though the world does not know
you I know you and they know that you
have sent me I have made you known to
them and will continue to make you known
in order that the love you have for me
may be in them and that I myself may be
in them and that I myself may be in
them where was Jesus going when he left
heaven and came to
earth right right
here right
there we were Jesus destination when he
left heaven in 1 Corinthians 6:19 the
Apostle Paul says do you not know that
your bodies are temples of the Holy
Spirit who is in you whom you have
received from
God Jesus died on the cross to cleanse
new temples for God's glory Christians
are the walking talking living breathing
temples of our
creator because of
Jesus reason seven to clear a path for
genuine
morality a common atheist
misunderstanding of Christian ethics is
that Christians only do the right thing
because we don't want to be punished in
Hell according to this view atheists who
do the right thing are better because
they do it just because it's right not
because they're trying to avoid hell
well this is a pretty ridiculous
caricature of Christian morality there
is an underlying valid point here what
if someone only does what's right
because of how it's going to benefit him
is he really doing what's right if he
only does it for selfish reasons in
other words you can help an old lady
cross the street because it's a good
thing to do but what if you help her
cross the street because someone pays
you to help her if I say to you hey help
that old lady across the street and I'll
give you 50 bucks and you do it to get
the 50 bucks have you done anything
morally
praiseworthy true morality isn't just
doing the right thing it's doing the
right thing for the right
reason there are two main obstacles to
doing the right thing for the right
reason one what if there isn't really a
right thing to do
that's the atheist threat to morality if
there's no real foundation for right and
wrong in atheism then morality comes
down to how you're wired and how you're
conditioned by society and so thinking
that something is objectively right or
wrong becomes a kind of
delusion two if you only do the right
thing to receive some reward or to avoid
being punished then everything you do is
done out of
selfishness that's the Islamic threat to
morality but in Christianity your good
deeds don't get you to heaven Jesus does
Ephesians 2 for it is by Grace you have
been saved through faith and this is not
from yourselves it is the gift of God
not by works so that no one can boast
for we are God's handiwork created in
Christ Jesus to do good works which God
prepared in advance for us to do
since God is real there's a real right
and wrong thus avoiding the atheist
obstacle to morality and even though we
do good works we're not doing these good
works because we think they'll earn us a
trip to Heaven thus avoiding the Islamic
obstacle to morality Christians do
what's right because it's right and
because we honor God and because we're
grateful not much room for selfishness
in Christian
ethics reason 8 to set an
example in Luke 9 Jesus says the son of
man must suffer many things and be
rejected by the elders the chief priests
and the teachers of the law and he must
be killed and on the third day be raised
to life then he said to them all whoever
wants to be my disciple must deny
themselves and take up their cross daily
and Follow
Me by laying down his life for the sake
of others Jesus set an example for his
followers and his followers definitely
got that message in Ephesians 5 the
Apostle Paul writes husbands love your
wives just as Christ loved the church
and gave himself up for her to make her
holy cleansing her by the washing with
water through the word and to present
her to himself self as a Radiant Church
Without stain or wrinkle or any other
blemish but holy and
blameless husbands should love their
wives enough to be ready to be crucified
for them why well look at what Jesus did
for his bride the
church in Philippians 2 Paul applies the
example set by Jesus to relationships in
general in your relationships with one
another have the same mindset as Christ
Jesus who being in very nature God did
not consider equality with God something
to be used to his own Advantage rather
he made himself Nothing by taking the
very nature of a servant being made in
human likeness and being found in
appearance as a man he humbled himself
by becoming obedient to death even death
on a cross therefore God exalted him to
the high place and gave him the name
that is above every name that at the
name of Jesus every knee should bow in
heaven and on Earth and under the Earth
and every tongue acknowledge that Jesus
Christ is Lord to the glory of God the
Father reason nine to shatter Dividing
Walls based on race class and
gender unfortunately human beings
usually don't have the same mindset as
Jesus in our relationships which is why
we have endless Division and hostility
we divide up the world and then we treat
people from different groups as enemies
but Jesus said in Matthew 5 you have
heard that it was said love your
neighbor and hate your enemy but I tell
you love your enemies and pray for those
who persecute you that you may be
children of your father in Heaven he
causes his son to rise on the evil and
the good and sends Reign on the
righteous and the
unrighteous if you love those who love
you what reward will you get are not
even the tax collectors doing that and
if you greet only your own people what
are you doing more than others do not
even the pagans do that be perfect
therefore as your heavenly father is
perfect all those people you view as
your enemies God loves them too not just
you and when we realize that we have not
only the same Creator but also the same
savior the walls that divide us come
tumbling down Galatians 3 so in Christ
Jesus you are all children of God
through faith for all of you who were
baptized into Christ have clothed
yourselves with Christ there is neither
Jew nor Gentile neither slave nor free
nor is there male male and female for
you are all one in Christ
Jesus if you belong to Christ then you
are Abraham's seed and HS according to
the
promise there are rich people and poor
people in the world there are men and
women there are different
races but there shouldn't be hostility
because we're all one in
Christ reason 10 to show us that God can
turn the greatest evil into the greatest
good what's the worst thing that could
possibly
happen here you might think about
something that would be worst to you
personally maybe your child dying or
something like that but if we leave all
of our personal views out of it I think
we might conclude that the worst thing
that could possibly happen would be the
creator of the universe who gave us life
and everything else we've ever had who
sustains us for every moment of our
existence miraculously entering into
creation healing people feeding people
telling people to love each other and
then getting brutally tortured and
executed like the world's most depraved
criminal that's the worst thing that
could possibly happen and yet it turned
out to be the best thing that ever
happened which means that God can turn
the greatest evil into the greatest
good this should always be embedded in
your thinking there's what's happening
in the world according to appearances
and there's what's really happening in
the world according to God's
purposes we can see how this thinking
impacted the earliest Christian
Community in Acts 4 persecution against
Christians is starting to warm up and
they gather together and
pray Sovereign Lord they said you made
the heavens and the earth and the Sea
and everything in them you spoke by the
Holy Spirit through the mouth of your
servant Our Father David why do the
Nations rage and the peoples plot in
vain the kings of the earth rise up and
the rulers ban together against the Lord
and against his anointed one indeed
Herod and Pontius Pilate met together
with the Gentiles and the people of
Israel in this city to conspire against
your holy servant Jesus whom you
anointed they did what your power and
will had decided beforehand should
happen these Christians acknowledge that
Herod and pilate and the Romans and the
Jewish leaders conspired against Jesus
but they also know that it was all part
of God's plan to bring Salvation to the
world how do you think that knowledge
helped them endure
persecution if God can take the worst
thing that could ever happen and turn it
into the greatest thing that could ever
happen what do you think he can do with
whatever problems you're
facing so why did Jesus have to die to
fulfill Old Testament prophecy to
establish a covenant to become a ransom
for many to demonstrate God's love to
give us his righteousness to transform
us into God's temples to clear a path
for genuine morality to set an example
to shatter Dividing Walls based on race
class and gender and to show us that God
can turn the greatest evil into the
greatest
good since you now know the why you can
endure the how as in how am I going to
get through this or how can I forgive
that person or how is the world going to
recover when so many people are going
completely
insane of course the Bible gives more
reasons for jesus' death if you'd like
to dig deeper John Piper wrote a short
book titled 50 reasons why Jesus came to
die covers several of the same points I
discussed here along with many many more
so if you'd like a few dozen additional
wise the link is in the description box
[Music]